hey this is a Gregory no and um Casa del
de Vega what's that like that Spanish
restaurant Casa de Vega Casa del Lago
has a notebook I'll take that has the
Nova we got in like a lot of requests
for this one
sir bomb is the first one requested
Deadpool musical Beauty and the Beast
Gaston parody I'm really excited
actually I saw this come up on Facebook
and I miss it and I forgot to click it
well excited
well you know I tested for the guest on
role I'm so global and I did I was like
nine second I was like nothing right
sure they're learning okay good I'm
really buzzed you feel like I could be a
guest on you know ya know when I first
met you I thought the same thing I was
like beat because forgot yeah my dick
you lessly handsome ladies love me
myself I think you could be everybody
why would you know God this video really
okay Wow Sean's a guy dad he's the guys
that's was the king she hasn't seen the
real-life movie yet yeah but you've seen
the cartoon yes in the cartoon I don't
know what's gonna happen
now the real well
oh yes I could have sworn the invite
said it was a costume party
that guy gets it loves the hip so what
can I change everyone's dressing like
what the 92 thought was pop oh come on
bartender me ask me rough day while you
rub the same spot over and over you ever
shut up no I'm a tad cocky
what are you gonna do so I'm outside
dope watch it
you stay here Deadpool it's going to get
ugly real fast
subscribe usually does look like my
balls under that loop just thinking of
it fills my bones
normally that would fit like a little
but damn it I've always wanted to be a
musical there's no man in town
until they all wish you would die even
though you prefer white Brazil every no
man in town has that truck you can add
Gannon a Dior fancy and they'll tell you
who certainly prefer to be Avenger X me
that's not mad I know her for a girl
plane but what's going on with history
so anyway sexy recon super Charlie's
Angels hope I could be your boss Lee
watch it in action
[Music]
oh lucky I wasn't happening from here
good thing for your art okay you're no
slouch in that way either exploit but
every last inches means dirtiest oh yeah
[ __ ]
[Music]
do you get on a trip like that who mom
especially good Wow reporter though when
I was a boy I hope this unicorn every
morning that like we get off but no II
think my hub of all fill me wrong is
that right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey I'll clean this [ __ ] up her Oh
perfect Wow Atlee that was so impressive
I was very well done happy a
post-credits thing that was like shot
incredibly well one one oil if I don't
gonna be like a fandom what yelling are
like a fad like that there was actually
Declan that was really well done fellas
are they're like yeah yeah we're at much
like we do the Beast coming out let's do
a trailer this will to trailer for that
[Music]
the girl who played Black Widow is a
friend of mine
I love either she likes I just texted
her like the other day action talk
British my cousin been on the channel
before kept rolling [ __ ] on the channel
is ended review what up to you you know
what Wow I run how much is coffee the
other special thanks to ride rattle me
yellow nonprofit non-commercial Wow girl
I'm gonna meet you this not product
let's replace a lot of money for film
that wooden here we go daddy
excuse me
that's why beautiful good [ __ ] yourself
Oh whoo let's go do that have you got
time for a fastball special two in the
pool one in the stool Wow hashtag people
musical damn I am impressed right now I
can see them putting together a full
thing like I guess like at least like an
hour long thing where they just kind of
take other popular musical numbers and
they just be Perry's on it but would get
pool spa me oh no not that bold I'll see
like I've seen this they should do that
just Deadpool yeah the guy boy Deadpool
was really good I mean yeah I thought
it's his vocal rhythm was a little bit
slower
yeah Ryan Reynolds well no one can match
that he's brilliant
yeah he's really kid Cadence's
unmatchable is like I've got certain
speed when he talks to you the scene was
really good the song was really
well-crafted the whole choreography was
great like it was like oh she's actual
violence yeah did a Hannah little guy
gets his head chopped off and you sort
of see I'm or so it does oh yeah yeah
yeah thanks for good the why I can't get
over the wife I was watching the bar see
the being I was like the lighting looks
like out of the actual movie I had the
first minute I thought was from the
movie no no good switch over and then
Irish in the whole thing oh god yes all
this was from the movie the girl plays
Black Widow much like she's down the
chat by a lot actually
oh really yeah I met her I met her like
years ago and YESCO because such you
know she she doesn't like a lot of
modeling and stuff but she's also like
this really good singer and she does
like stunts oh so this is like
everything yeah and she's talking she's
gonna talk about her by coming back on
the channel again soon so you're like
singing and like doing kicks and shaded
like all the crap man I'm glad you're
getting the exposure I would have right
around so seen this right around is like
she that's crazy how Deadpool it just
fascinates me how Deadpool was this like
work in progress for like 10 years they
couldn't get Greenland done that until
what what happened was they they
released like test footage for a
Deadpool movie that like it was pretty
much like the opening of the movie
perfect but they didn't they only shot
that it was a lot of it was visual
effects and running out with the
voiceover and stuff and people loved it
it got leaked and because of the fandom
and of like this is great we want our
Deadpool movie please and they made it
and became this like monstrous in it you
know well change the comics and
everything like that and why so good
it's given us this cool movie that's
also hilarious and very meta and breaks
the fourth wall movie I think like no
one else could do it but no there's no
one else
perfect oh my god no it may be Mel
Gibson what now well I'll get what no
yeah
Paul Rudd is the only other person like
oh yeah so endearing and likable but no
matter what he does do it I don't think
you could have had it but I mean it's
Grundy is dark it's a little pervert
Italy I just think when you read a
Deadpool comic it's like that's Ryan
right there like there's nothing held
out about it like that's Ryan right it's
got like this high energy with like to
ride wit as well
I feel like Paul runs a lot more like
dude subdued Morse's this yeah he's like
sort of Catholic he's funny but his
Energy's not quite the level of it no
one has that energy like yeah he works
out all the time that all like lesbians
doing any worry that all the guys office
you know I've your workout often enough
to get more energy like I didn't work
out or dance I'm a little more lethargic
you know you work out don't you work out
like six days a week
p90x I know we're having exhausting at
first but what you do is consistently it
brings you more energy done there Billy
yeah well you know that I mean I hear it
I don't believe it
well he's got working out a little more
you find out I know I won't do like
parkour like that's working out that's
working out yeah okay good but I'll do
that always fun
also um what else is there sex you have
sex no laughing come on the indoor rock
wall in downtown yeah you get a sector
know the raw balls gonna be minute no I
want to go really bad what's going
inside in like a huge warehouse that
they converted it's like everything I've
been there before they converted it okay
well let's go because I'm adventurous
are you okay good let's go are you still
you are you come to other things listen
anything you say come to I come that's
just the way I operate yeah some of this
that's what I mean I mean you're
adventurous and outdoorsy yeah look
we've really not I'm just trying to show
this lie to you make myself more
attractive it's really hard it's really
hard it's a really hard no I'm not that
outdoors either in my mind I am not
realizing ya know I just keep [ __ ] okay
let's make her laugh let's go out to
learn archery
it's not even more than I am oh yeah I'm
watching youtube videos I'm not trying
to impress you but whatever well back
from the video I described the real
rejects hey congratulations the Deadpool
said that cool upsetting old challenge
Ephraim Wow
grassy you guys make more please leave a
lot lot more than those good Cassidy
Lehrman he could follow her on Instagram
yeah she is the sage of my life Oh
[Music]
who knows fun I'm glad we did it all
right now say goodbye to the world I'm
gonna do the like really no I'm totally
kidding no you think how exhausting can
you see if you can't no yeah you can say
a little bit okay for Kamisha no I'm
definitely not mean you're crazy you
should really enhance execution sorry
you didn't impression you can probably
see yeah I need I need like a rock band
thing so I could see the arrow so I know
what no time hitting I want to do that
I've never done it no don't walk around
mind it's like years ago
I have rock band I know that's excited
about that